[Musique]
à quoi pense-t-il Charles de Gaulle en
regardant passer le cercueil de Winston
Churchill à quelques mètres de lui le
jour de ses funérailles
à la cathédrale Saint-Paul de Londres le
30 janvier
1965 il est vrai qu'ils se sont tant
aimés ou plutôt admirés détestés
réconciliés violemment fâché à nouveau
avant de se retrouver à
jamais ils se sont affrontés en chef de
guerre en alliés en politicien en
négociateur en chef d'État en camarad de
tant de combats et finalement le dernier
mais pas le moindre ils se sont
affrontés en écrivains de véritables
écrivains mais Rivau à l'heure de
publier leur mémoire de guerre et de
graver dans le marbre de la postérité
chacun à sa façon sa propre version de
leur histoire
[Musique]
commune
c'est l'un de ces endroits devenus
historiqueques où je ressens comme nulle
part ailleurs la présence des
morts difficile de pénétrer dans la
Boisserie de Charles de Gaulle sa
gentillomière de colomber les deux
églises dans la Haute Marne sans
ressentir qu'elle est
habitée toute sa personnalité son
caractère transparaissent ici dans
chacun des meubles dans chaque biblot
dans chaque gravure dans sa bibliothèque
et dans le choix de conserver des livres
de jeunesse ce qui ne peut laisser
insensible l'écrivain en moi un peu plus
loin là dans cette table de bridge sur
laquelle il faisait régulièrement en fin
de journée des réussites ma discipline
d'oisiveté comme il disait tout est
resté en l'état dans sa simplicité même
il est mort à quelques mètres de son
bureau là où ivre de son nez seulement
il ne conçoit pas d'écrire autrement sa
haute silhouette arqueboutée sur son
bureau son stylo à ancre glissant sur la
rame de papier isolé de la rumeur du
monde sa fenêtre donnant sur l'apreté de
la campagne
champenoise un écrivain est un solitaire
Charles de Gaulle n'a pas à forcer sa
nature la présence de son ami Winston
Churchill est assurée par son portrait
trôant parmi les grandes ceonde et
surtout par ses mémoires apporté de sa
main la publication simultanée de leur
mémoire de guerre à la charnière des
années 40 et 50 a été un événement
mondial ils y ont fait œuvre d'écrivain
cela paraît inimaginable avec le recul
mais Churchill a même été couronné de la
récompense suprême le prix Nobel de
littérature
mais des deux était-ce le bon
lauréa pour en juger il ne faut pas
seulement s'arrêter à leur statut de
chef de guerre ce qu'ils ont été sur le
front mais revenir aux œuvres
elles-mêmes et surtout à la dimension
humaine de ces deux écrivains
soldats il faut aussi reconsidérer ces
Mémoires de guerre d'un point de vue
littéraire en bénéficiant du recul du
temps 70 années se sont écoulées depuis
la parution de ces livres qui ont connu
un succès considérable à l'époque et on
le sait bien on gagne toujours à séparer
les livres du bruit qu'ils
[Musique]
font pour comprendre pourquoi leur
mémoire demeurent un témoignage
essentiel il faut d'abord traverser la
campagne anglaise si chè à Sir Winston
car la volonté des deux auteurs de
s'inscrire aussi comme écrivain dans
notre mémoire nous invite à les juger
aussi comme
tel transportonsnous donc dans ces
manuscrits là où ceux-ci sont protégés
des regards indiscrets à l'égal de
documents explosifs aux archives
entreposées dans un bâtiment à
l'université de Cambridge un chercheur
gagne toujours à se reportter aux
documents
originaux même s'il n'a pas affaire à
des manuscrits mais à des tapuscrit la
graphie de l'auteur en marge sont
tremblé parfois l'importance de ces
corrections la nature de ses remords ses
rajous et ses suppressions tout cela
compte à les lire je croirais l'entendre
parler c'est le cas lorsqu'il évoque le
départ de De Gaulle pour Londres le 17
juin
1940 difficile de ne pas en faire son
miel
dès que l'appareil commence à rouler de
GO sauta dedans et claqua la porte
l'avion pris son envol tandis que
policiers et fonctionnaires français
restaient bougeb dans ce petit avion de
GA emportait avec lui l'honneur de la
France lorsqu'il raconte à son tour le
même événement de Gaulle est plus sec et
plus
lapidaire le départ sans romantisme et
sans
[Musique]
difficulté pour comprendre un écrivain
ces manuscrits ne suffisent pas son
style littéraire est en harmonie avec
son style de vie il faut se rendre sur
ses lieux le visiter dans le motif comme
on le dirait d'un peintre en pleine
nature à chartwell dans le
Kent
Winston Churchill offre une toute autre
image de l'écrivain au travail quand on
va chez
lui il privilégiait lui aussi ses séjour
au vert dans son domaine plein d'animaux
un endroit extrêmement chaleureux et
attachant aux yeux de tout anglophile
décs que l'on jurerait
churchillissim après tout la vie est
trop courte pour être
petite cette folie car CEN est une eu
égard au coup de son entretien a été en
partie financé par certains de ses amis
quelques hommes riches et puissants de
son premier cercle pour l'autre partie
par les revenus de ses nombreux écrits
dans la presse ou en librairie non qu'il
e la plume facile c'est simplement qu'il
était disons organisé
son œvre a donc été nourrie par une
passion pour la chose politique comme
chez peu d'écrivains ce qui témoigne
qu'être un homme d'action n'empêche pas
de produire oui mais à quel
prix I was 25 years old I written as
many books as
Moses writing a book is an
adventure to begin with it is a
toy and an
amusement and then it becomes a
mistress and then it becomes a
master and then it becomes a
tent in the last
days is that just you are about to be
reconciled to
pour dominer cette bête il a sa méthode
les six volumes consacrés à la Seconde
Guerre mondiale écrit entre 1948 et 1954
n'y échappe pas il n'écrit pas vraiment
mais dicte depuis un lieu pour le moins
intime son lit dans lequel on le trouve
assis ou couché un cigare dans une main
un verre de whisky dans l'autre papiers
et documents étalés sur sa
couverture il y a en permanence une ou
deux secrétaires à ses côtés lesquels
sont légèrement embarrassé lorsqu'il
dicte non plus depuis son lit mais
depuis son étrange baignoire la porte
grande
ouverte la surface de l'eau est couverte
de mousse mais tout de même
shocking ce dont il se fiche royalement
et même
impérialement pour écrire Churchill fait
appel à des dactyos et surtout à ses
assistants littéraires ainsi qu'il nomme
ceux qui sont en fait ses les
biographes ont pu en dresser une liste
de
6 pour prendre la mesure de son petit
consortium il faut se rendre au
rez-de-chaussée du manoir où les
machines à écrire se font
face les collaborateurs fournissent la
base la recherche documentaire puis il
rédige les grandes lignes Church réécrit
l'ensemble car le style est l'homme même
soit si l'anglais est innombrable
lorsqu'il écrit le français de Gaulle
dont le portrait figure dans cette pièce
devenue si symbolique lui est seul cela
correspond tellement à son
tempérament
[Musique]
si l'on est sensible au génie des lieux
alors on peut dire que la Boisserie à
colomberé les deux églises était faite
pour Charles de Gaul de proportions
raisonnables décoré sans ostentation il
l'avait acquise à un prix très sage en
1934 surtout elle était nimbée d'un
passé littéraire ce qui n'était pas fait
pour lui
déplaire car le détail est peu connu
mais pendant les SEP années qui ont
précédé sa présence les Jolas un couple
d'intellectuels américains y ont fait
souffler le vent de l'avant-garde
littéraire et artistique sous la double
influence du romantisme allemand et du
surréalisme ils y habitaient à Colombé
ils y fabriquaient à la Boisserie une
revue et y publièrent tant de textes
d'arau ou de Michot sans oublier le
principal leur grande fierté James
Joyce reste à savoir si quelque chose de
Joyce a déteint sur De Gaulle à supposé
que deux génies puissent cohabiter dans
les mêmes
lieux la solitude de l'écrivain de
Gaulle c'est celle d'un individualiste à
l'esprit d'équipe à Colomb ses
assistants se comptent sur les doigts
d'une main plutôt des relecteurs dont
l'écrivain André
merau ils ont la vertu de savoir
décrypter ses pattes de mouche talent
qui n'est accordé qu'à ceux qui ont
l'habitude de son écriture la mieux à
même de l'aider c'est encore sa fille
Élisabeth de Boissieux elle doit taper à
la machine des textes qui sont si
surchargés qu'ils finissent par
ressembler à des tableaux
d'aléchinski c'est avec un modus
opérandi aussi sobre et économe entouré
d'une équipe aussi légère que de Gaul a
écrit ses mémoires de guerre en
[Musique]
solitaire il en est des histoires
d'amitié comme des histoires d'amour on
n'oublie jamais les premières fois
généralement cela se passe mal si la
première rencontre entre ces deux hommes
de caractère n'échappe pas à la règle à
la deuxième cela s'arrange le courant
passe mais ce n'est pas nécessairement
un courant
alternatif car si l'anglais est
chaleureux le Français a tout d'un
poisson froid sinon congelé monsieur
Churchill me reçut à Downing Street
c'était la première fois que je prenais
contact avec lui il me parut être de
plein pied avec la tâche la plus rude
pourvu qu'elle fut aussi grandiose
par-dessus tout il est de par son
caractère fait pour agir risquer jouer
le rôle très carrément et sans
scrupule je vis le général de Gaulle qui
se tenait près de l'entrée immobile et
flegmatique en le saluant je lui dis à
mi- voix en français l'homme du destin
il resta impassible sous son attitude
imperturbable il me parut avoir une
surprenante sensibilité à la douleur
c'est une impression que j'ai conservé
depuis au contact de cet homme très
grand et
flegmatique voici le connaitable de
France leur style littéraire diffèr mais
au-delà de cette seule dimension tout
dans leur personnalité leur caractère
leur mode de vie leur style quoi tout
les
oppose là le français est un homme qui
marche une silhouette sculptée par
jacometti au perché toujours en
mouvement vers l'avant et souvent en
tenue d'officiers de charge juguchés sur
des grandes bottes un
hon l'autre c'est une masse mais une
masse paisible qui s'applique à
respecter ces deux devises celle d'un
homme assis dans un
fauteuil il dit souvent ne jamais rester
debout quand vous pouvez être assis et
ne jamais être assis si vous pouvez être
ouch l'anglais déborde d'émotion de
vivacité de sentimentalisme francophile
depuis l'invention du champagne il
maîtrise bien notre
langue c'est moi Churchill qui vous
parle pendant plus de 30 ans j'ai marché
avec vous et je marche encore avec
vous il est adulé par les Anglais qui
voient en lui un sauveur c'est
incontestablement son moment il lui faut
le saisir il a d'autant moins de mal à
endosser l'habit de héros national qu'il
se rêve tel depuis l'enfance jusqu'à sa
jeunesse sous les drapeaux il est vrai
qu'elles se sont déroulé dans un décor
majestueux
[Musique]
c'est à blinheim Palace cet univers
royal et impérial l'immense château
familial dont il est sorti avec la
promesse faite à lui-même d'être un jour
à la hauteur des
siens ces jeunes années se déroulèrent à
l'ombre des tableaux et des tapis des
grandes batailles accroché au mur qu'il
reconstituait en disposant ses soldat de
plomb sur le
[Musique]
tapis ce fut le théâtre de son
imaginaire là où il se procheta en digne
héritier de John Churchill premier duc
de marborough et chef de
guerre à force de vivre parmi les
souvenirs glorieux de ses ancêtres
Churchill s'est ement identifié à leur
figure légendaire jusqu'à se projeter
dans l'avenir comme le rempart de sa
[Musique]
nation à la Boisserie chez De Gaulle la
bibliothèque reflète non seulement
l'esprit et la culture mais surtout
l'âme de ce grand lecteur les héros de
son enfance ont été ceux de la nation et
non de la
[Musique]
famille pour de Gaulle tout doit passer
par l'écrit et la littérature dans un
lexique un ton inspiré du grand siècle
d'où sont issus les Bossuet et les
fenelons dont les livre ont bercé son
adolescence au côté des grands auteurs
des humanités classiques les Romains et
les Grecs
elle s'est déroulé dans une famille de
fonctionnaires et de juris parisiens de
sérieux érudit et des catholiques
légitimistes qui lui ont transmis le
goût des études et du service de
l'État à 15 ans il se décrivait déjà en
général de Gaulle sauvant la France
d'ors nun ne s'étonne à l'école
militaire de saint-cy qu'il n'envisage
pas d'autre carrière que le service des
armes Churchill non plus qui nimaginait
pas un seul instant faire ses classes
ailleurs qu' sainhurst le saintir
anglais mais c'est bien leur seul
véritable point
[Musique]
commun on a vu des couples mieux parti
dans la vie en tout cas mieux assorti
Churchill qui a 16 ans de plus que lui
confie à un proche ce de Gaulle
ressemble à un lama femelle surpris dans
son bain un jugement profond qui ne
manque pas
d'imagination l'intéressé n'est pas en
reste à la sortie d'une réunion du
cabinet de guerre il sourit à la vue du
nœud papillon à poid qui se détache sur
la chemise à carreaux de l'anglais en
lui faisant remarquer tiens c'est
carnaval aujourd'hui à quoi le Premier
ministre répond du tacot tac que
voulez-vous tout le monde ne peut pas se
déguiser en soldat inconnu il semble que
les deux avaient le sens de l'humour
mais celui de de Gaul était si discret
qu'on le cherche
encore pas d'intimité pas de tape dans
le dos pas de familiarité avec lui
qu'importe puisqu'ils sont d'accord sur
l'essentiel il est premier ministre et
de Gaulle n'est qu'un sous-secrétaire
d'État à la Défense nationale pourtant
dès son arrivée à Londres il le traite
déjà en égal en qualité de chef des
Français
Libres naufragé de la D sur les rivage
de l'Angleterre qu'aurais-je pu faire
sans son concours il me le donna tout de
suite et mis pour commencer la BBC à ma
disposition moi général de Gaul
j'entreprends ici en Angleterre cette
tâche
nationale j'invite tous les militair
français des armé de terre de mer et de
l'air à se réunir à moi
à mesure que s'envolaient les mots
irrévocables je sentais en moi-même se
terminer une vie celle que j'avais mené
dans le cadre d'une France solide et
d'une indivisible armée à 49 ans
j'entrai dans l'aventure comme un homme
que le destin jetait hors de toutes les
[Musique]
séries
c'est grâce à churchilleld qu'il peut
s'installer au 4 Carlton Gardens une
prestigieuse résidence encadré de
colonne Doric et de colonade
corinthienne le quartier général des
Forces Françaises
Libres difficile d'imaginer qu'à son
arrivée au début de l'été 1940 il
n'était rien un paria un hor la looi un
officier fon sans troupe ni soutien
international un homme
seul vive la France libre dans l'honneur
et dans
l'indépendance un homme seul un rebelle
dressé de toute sa violence sa colère et
son indignation contre le maréchal Pétin
et le régime de
Vichy la vieillesse est un
naufrage pour que rien ne nous fut
épargné la vieillesse du maréchal Pétin
allait s'identifier avec le naufrage de
la
France
de semaines après à Londres les Forces
françaises libres sont créés sur le
papier de Gaulle est rejoint par de
rares civils quelques milliers de
soldats des centaines d'officiers
d'aviateur des
marins en France on raille ses forces en
le décrivant entouré de journalistes
Juifs d'aristocrates et de pêcheurs de
l'île de Saint ce qui n'est pas faux non
plus et pourtant il est persuadé
d'incarner la France par lui restauré
dans son honneur et dans sa
dignité on dira que sa PL de Gaulle
prédispose même dans un anglais disons
assez
personnel
franceance
[Musique]
de fait un jour il sera le seul Français
à pouvoir dire en public moi la France
sans être aussitôt transféré à
saintanne Churchill supporte
difficilement l'attitude implacable
irréaliste d'un de Gaulle habité sinon
hanté toute sa vie durant par une
certaine idée de la France il lui arrive
même de perdre patience et s'emporter
auprès de ses
collaborateurs ce type est un
dingue nous fimmes néanmoins de notre
mieux pour accroître son influence son
autorité et son pouvoir de son côté il
prenait naturellement fort mal toute
relation de notre part avec les gens de
Vichy et considérait que nous lui
devions une loyauté exclusive il jugeait
également essentiel à sa position aux
yeux du peuple français de conserver une
attitude fière et hautaine envers la
perfide
Albion du latin perfidia qui signifie
mauvaise foi si perfide Albion que de
Gaulle a toujours éprouvé non pas une
certaine détestation
dansangleterre mais une profonde
méfiance vis-à-vis
d'elle ce sentiment est revivifié début
juillet
[Musique]
1940 les Anglais veulent à tout prix
empêcher le
de s'emparer des bâtiments de guerre
français stationnés à Mersel Kebir un
port
d'Algérie après des ultimatum la Royal
Navy coule la plus grande partie de
l'escadre
française sont incend par les obus
britanniques un puissant de Gaul subit
son anéantissement qu'il finit par
justifier dans ses
Mémoires m'adressant au français
je leur demande de considérer le fond
des choses du seul point de vue qui doiv
finalement compter c'est-à-dire du point
de vue de la victoire et de la
délivrance je dis sans embage qu'il vaut
mieux que les navires aient été détruits
nos deux vieux peuples nos deux grands
peuples demeurent liés l'un à l'autre
ils succomberont tous les deux ou bien
ils gagneront
ensemble ce fut une décision odieuse la
plus inhumaine la plus pénible de toutes
celles quel j'ai été associé c'était une
tragédie
grecque pourtant jamais aucun acte ne
fut plus nécessaire à la survie de
l'Angleterre et de tous ceux qui
comptaient sur
elle près de 1500 marins il laisse la
vie le nationalisme de De Gaulle mis
devant le fait accompli est très ébranlé
car le sang français a coulé aussi peu
après c'est lui qui est à la manœuvre
pour inciter ch chill a s'emparé de la
marine française à
Dakar mal préparé l'opération aboutit à
un douloureux fiasco qu'il vivent
solidairement dans la même
[Musique]
galère lorsqu'il fend l'armure et se
confie à des proches le général
reconnaît le coup de blouse abattu il
broie du noir c'est peu de le dire pour
la seule fois de sa vie il est hanté par
des pulsions
suicidaires les jours qui suivirent me
furent cruels j'ai prouva les
impressions d'un homme dont un séisme
secoue brutalement la maison et qui
reçoit sur la tête la pluie des tuiles
tombant du
toit Churchill lui est coutumier de cet
état d'âme sa mélancolie issue d'un état
dépressif latant il l'a domestiqué même
si elle le fait souffrir par un
coup il l'a surnommé mon Black Dog et
l'arrivée de ce chien noir s'annonce à
chaque fois par un grand coup qui s'abat
sur sa nuque et qu'il surmonte en se
noyant dans l'alcool plus encore qu'à
l'accoutumé mais ce qui s'abat sur la
nuque de son peuple c'est un déluge de
feu et d'acier lancé à partir du 7
septembre 1940 par la lftte VA
8 mois durant ce BL l'éclair en allemand
pousse les habitants à se terrer dans
les caves les abris le métro londonien à
plus de 50 m de
[Musique]
profondeur pour prendre la mesure de cet
enfermement il faut se rendre là où
s'enterrit le cabinet de guerre dirigé
par Churchill son bunker secret est
situé en plein centre de la
capitale il abrite de nombreuses pi
pièce dans un labyrinthe de galerie
conservé à
l'identique voici le bruit qui fait
partie intégrante de la vie de Chac
homme de chaque femme et de chaque
enfant
[Musique]
d'Angleterre Churchill y a rarement vécu
avec sa femme ses ministres et les
officiers de son staff il y a parfois
participé à des réunions stratégiques
sur la conduite de la guerre et
l'organisation des
[Musique]
batailles
la présence de grande carte géographique
qui tapissent toutes les pièces les
salles de réunion comme les chambre en
témoigne c'est dans cette atmosphère
oppressante car enterré que Churchill a
passé une partie de son temps jour et
nuit à réfléchir à hclclos à dormir à
décider et surtout à encourager son
peuple au micro de la BBC installé à cet
effet
la manière dont il évoque ces moments-là
dans ses Mémoires rappelle son talent de
journaliste activité dans laquelle il a
longtemps exercé sa plume avant de se
jeter dans la carrière littéraire les
raides de nuit s'accompagnaient
d'attaques de jour plus ou moins
continuelles mené par de petites
formations ennemies ou même par des
appareils isolés et souvent les sirènes
retentissaient à de brefs intervalles
tout au long des 24 Heures d'une journée
les 7 millions d'habitants de Londres
finir par s'accoutumer à cette étrange
existence au fond si haut que soit le
premier ministre britannique et le chef
de la France libre ne relève-t-ils pas
eux aussi de cette foule qui redresse la
tête dès le lendemain des bombardements
de Londres et de Covent
une foule que chur évoque comme des gens
ordinaires confrontés à une époque
[Musique]
extraordinaire une formule winstonissime
que de Gaul reprend
sonte
J la terre non tant attendu de
[Musique]
nous je les imagine bien l'un et l'autre
Churchill et de Gaulle touché par cette
photographie accrochée à un mur de mon
bureau cette image est l'une des plus
iconiques du
Blitz la bibliothèque de Haren House à
Londres dévastée par des bombes larguées
par l'aviation allemande sur ce quartier
de
l'ouest des personnages cherche un livre
dans les rayonnages en ruine comme si de
rien
n'était il y a là quelque chose de
surréel qui reflète bien la folie de
l'époque et l'absurdité d'une guerre si
dévastatrice les bibliothèques ont pour
vocation de conserver protéger et
communiquer les livres non d'être le
spectacle morbide de leur
destruction
les livres nos deux hommes de guerre ont
toujours vécu dans et par
eux les manuscrits des mémoires de
guerre du général ont été naturellement
accueillis par la Bibliothèque nationale
à Paris les consultés relèvent d'un
cérémonial qui a parti lié avec le
sacré ces pages originales ne s'y
laissent découvrir que sur dérogation et
avec 1LE précautions à commencer par
l'usage exclusif du crayon à mine pour
prendre des notes surtout pas d'encre de
crainte d'un
[Musique]
accident sous la plume de De Gaulle une
écriture la sienne nerveuse tendue
surchargée pleine de rature et donc de
remords ce qui reflète au fond sa
recherche obsessionnelle du mot juste il
correspond à la définition qu'Oscar
Wilde donnée d'un
écrivain quelqu'un qui passe sa matinée
à rajouter une virgule et son après-midi
à la
retirer il est intéressant de comparer
l'état de leur manuscrit avec Churchill
il s'agit d'un tapuscrit puisqu'il dicte
mais jusqu'à la fin pour ne pas déplaire
aux uns et aux autres et se conformer à
leur désirs c'est plein de barré et
remplacé par d'autres afin de ne vexer
personne à commencer par De Gaulle ainsi
a-t-il éliminé les passages où il le
traite de je cite fureur en germe donc
des mots barrés à l'aide d'un crayon à
mine bleu donnant un autre type de
tableau ce que le pastelliste en lui
passionné par toutes les nuances du bleu
n'aurait pas
renié la grande qualité de Churchill qui
fait pour l'instant défaut à de Gaulle
c'est que dès qu'il parle en public il
le met dans sa poche paradoxalement
c'est là que le styliste se révèle en
lui car sa grande œuvre ce sont ses
discours ce qui ne va pas de soi pour un
homme affecté d'un défaut de
prononciation un
[Musique]
Z
des qualités oratoires que de Gaul
reconna lu env quel que F son auditoire
qu' se trouva devant un micro à la
tribune à table ou derrière un bureau le
flot original poétique émouvant de ses
idées argument sentim lu procur un
ascendant presqueaillible dans
l'ambiance dramatique le pauvre monde ce
monde tourne vraiment sur S lorsque les
États-Unis entrent en guerre en décembre
1941 malgré l'admiration que de Gaulle
voe à Churchill leur relation connaî à
nouveau une période de glaciation avec
l'arrivé d'un troisème homme qui
s'impose alors entre eux de toute sa
puissance le président Franklin
Roosevelt Churchill proche de lui pour
des raisons tant historiques que
personnelles sa propre mère était
américaine se rapproche d'avantage
encore un pas de deux qui exclut le
français l'ANT est que Roosevelt est
désormais le leadership du monde
[Musique]
libre la détestation de Roosevelt pour
de Gaul est notoire il voit en lui un
apprenti
dictateur non seulement il le méprise
mais il tente d'y entraîner qui se
retrouve écartelé entre deux
[Musique]
fidélités Roosevelt et Churchill ont un
plan pour mener l'offensive depuis
l'Afrique du Nord mais il ne souhaite
pas y associer de Gaulle si nous avions
mêlé de Gaulle à l'affaire cela aurait
produit le plus fâcheux effet sur les
réactions des Français d'Afrique du Nord
pourtant il fallait manifestement
trouver quelques hautes personnalité
française et aux yeux des Britanniques
comme des Américains nul ne semblait
plus qualifié que le général
[Musique]
Giro le général Giro est plus souple
plus accommodant et tellement plus
chaleureux que l'insupportable de Gaulle
il est le pion idéal pour les Américains
et un rival de taille pour de Gaul
désormais sur la touche nous parl de
rousvelt et de son attitude à mon égard
ne brusquez rien dit Monsieur Churchill
voyez comment tour à tour je plie et me
relève vous le pouvez observje parce que
vous êtes assis sur un état solide une
nation rassemblé un empire uni de
grandes armées mais moi où sont mes
moyens pourtant j'ai vous le savez la
charge des intérêts et du destin de la
France c'est trop lourd et je suis trop
pauvre pour que je puisse me
courber monsieur Churchill conclut notre
entretien par une démonstration d'amitié
et d'émotion nous av encore de rudes
obstacles à surmonter mais un jour nous
serons en France peut-être l'année
prochaine en tout cas nous y serons
ensemble je ne vous lâcherai
pas et pourtant Churchill organise une
opération d'envergure avec le président
américain une ligne transatlantique
spéciale permet même au Premier ministre
britannique de s'entretenir à tout
instant avec
lui les état-major ourdissent en secret
l'opération torche un débarquement de
troupes alliées en Afrique du Nord en
novembre 1942 et de Gaulle est exclu de
tous ces
préparatifs j'avais conscience des liens
qui nous unissaient à de Gaulle et de la
gravité de l'affront que nous allions
lui infliger en le tenant délibérément à
l'écart de toute participation à
l'entreprise j'avais l'intention de
l'informer juste avant que le coup ne Fû
porté
[Musique]
ce débarquement mené sur les plages
d'Algérie et du Maroc permet aux alliés
de prendre pied sur le
africain c'est leur première grande
victoire militaire et de Gaul n'en est
pas c'est aussi que Roosevelt a son
homme et il n'en démore pas le général
Giro qui tient à installer à la tête de
l'armée
[Musique]
d'Afrique de toute évidence l'orgueil de
de Gaul est agressé au plus haut par ses
alliés monsieur Churchill s'en prit
alors à moi sur un ton asserbe et
passionné il s'écria avec fureur vous
dites que vous êtes la France vous
n'êtes pas la France je ne vous
reconnais pas comme la France puis
toujours véhément la France où
est-elle comment n'en concevrait-il pas
une humiliation d'autant plus cruelle
que la conférence d'enfa se déroule en
janvier 1943 devant les caméras
internationales
Roosevelt et Churchill prépar déjà leur
stratégie pour la prèsguerre manifestant
sa colère froide face à son exclusion
donc celle de la France de Gaul arrive
en retard allant même jusqu'à les faire
attendre de jours de Gaul arriva enfin
le 22 janvier et fut conduite à sa ville
qui était voisine de celle de Gir il
refusa d'aller rendre visite à ce
dernier et il fallut plusieurs heures
d'effort pour le décider à changer
d'avis j'us un entretien glacial avec de
Gaulle et lui fit très clairement
comprendre que nous n'hésiterions pas à
rompre définitivement avec lui s'il
persistait dans son
opposition le Premier ministre m'adressa
des reproches amèes où je ne pu voir
autre chose que l'alibi de l'embara il
m'annonça qu'en rentrant à Londres il
m'accuserait publiquement d'avoir
empêché l'entendre
dress contre ma personne l'opinion de
son pays et en appeller à celle de la
France de toute la guerre ce fut la plus
r des rencontres de Gaul se résout
finalement à s'asseoir à la table des
négociations pour être agréable à
Churchill qui aura beaucoup insisté un
moment historique totalement fabriqué il
dira même à rosevelt
à autrement dit si je le fais c'est bien
pour
vous
roselt le pousse à faire une seconde
prise pour la bonne cause
sodant de GA qui sort du cadre dirige
désormais conjointement avec le général
GIR les forces françaises en
[Musique]
guerre
monsieur Churchill chaque fois que nous
nous heurtions en raison des intérêts
dont nous avions respectivement la
charge faisait de notre désaccord comme
une affaire personnelle il en était
blessé et chagriné à proportion de
l'amitié qui nous liait l'un à l'autre
ses dispositions de l'esprit et du
sentiment jointes au recettes de sa
tactique politique le jeta dans des
crise de colère qui secouait rudement
nos
rapports ce que ve les Anglo-Saxons
c'est rien moins que la miss sous
tutelle américaine de la France ce qui
est aux yeux de De Gaulle inacceptable
inenvisageable et non
négociable on comprend dès lors que de
Gaulle subisse un 3è affront il est
exclu des préparatifs du jour J le
débarquement en Normandie le 6 juin
à 6h30 les premières troupes d'assaut et
les chars des Alliés débarquent sur les
plages
normandes au même moment celui que l'on
surnomme le général micro est réduit à
US de la BBC cette fois pour sauver
l'honneur Assur la présence de la France
libre et de son chef en ce jour
historique après tempant de combat de
fureur de douleur voici venu le choc
décisif c'est la bataille de France et
c'est la bataille de la France la
circonstance le pousse à être plus
lyrique qu'à l'accoutumé en adoptant une
fois de plus des accents churchiliens
derrière le nuage si lourd de notre sang
et de nos larmes voici
que reparaît le soleil de notre
grandeur de Gaul lui a débarqué en
Normandie 6 jours après les autres il
n'a qu'une idée en tête libérer Paris
pour les Alliés c'est un objectif
secondaire ils veulent même contourner
la capitale mais de Gaulle n'en démore
pas et il faut que ce soit des Français
ceux de la deuxème division blindée du
général Leclerc qui entre les premiers
dans Paris
et que ce soit lui le général de Gaulle
qui incarne la libération la plus
symbolique au regard de la postérité une
exigence de plus qui agace son allié
Churchill ce type de Gou est
insupportable et c'est lui qui a raison
la France la seule France la France
libre c'est lui et nul autre et dans
l'avenir ce sera lui aussi vrai que moi
Churchill je serai celui de
l'Angleterre
[Musique]
le 25 août 1944 le général de Gaulle
entre dans Paris en
vainqueur mais jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
il boycotera les commémorations du Jour
le plus
long je ranime la flamme depuis le 14
juin 40 nul n'avait pu le faire qu'en
présence de
l'envahisseur puis je quitte la voûte et
le terreplein les assistants s'écartent
devant moi les Champs-Élysées
ah c'est la
mer une foule immense émassée de part et
d'autre de la chaussée peut-être 2
millions
[Musique]
d'âes
nous aurons ainsi tous ensemble
bouleversé fraternel sentant la joie la
fierté l'espérance nationale remonté du
fond des
[Musique]
Abî il s'agit aujourd'hui de rendre à
lui-même par le spectacle de sa joie et
l'évid de sa liberté un peuple qui fut
hier écrasé par la défaite et dispersé
par la
servitude de toutes les images du
général prise ou filmé pendant la guerre
c'est la première fois qu'on le voit
enfin le sourire
[Musique]
l'èvre lorsqu'il accueillera le Premier
ministre anglais 2 mois plus tard c'est
bien de son ami Church qu'il s'agira à
nouveau l'un comme l'autre au fê de leur
gloire de goume reçut un grand déjeuner
au ministère de la guerre et prononça
des paroles extrêmement flatteuses au
sujet de mon rôle durant le conflit je
fut frappé par le respect voire la
crainte qu'une demi-douzaine de généraux
de haut grade témoignaiit à de gaaule
bien qu'il n'ut qu'une étoile sur son
uniforme
[Musique]
les deux chefs de guerre se retrouvent
face- à faceace pour l'éternité en bas
des Champs Élysées le sculpteur les a
incarné en homme qui marche ils sont
l'histoire mais se dirige toujours vers
l'avant dès la fin de la guerre il
continue à dominer le paysage
politique le 13 novembre 1945 de Gaul
est élu président du gouvernement
[Musique]
oire mais Churchill lui tombe de son
socle il est balayé aux élections par un
r demaré
[Musique]
travailliste désenchanté il se met au
vert dans son domaine de chartwell en
retrait pour R ire ses Mémoires de
guerre fidèle à sa promesse d'être
l'historien d'une épopée dont il avait
été également le héros il produit avec
son équipe six tomes dont le premier
paraî en
[Musique]
1948 Churchill devient un auteur à
succès car les ventes de son UV sont
considérables et durables tant aux
États-Unis qu'en
Angleterre
à la librairie harchards à Londres il
est même le seul à bénéficier de tout un
pan de bibliothèque dédié à ses propres
livre ainsi qu'à tous ceux nombreux qui
ont été consacrés à ce
jour pendant ce temps le général de
Gaulle qui a quitté le pouvoir et qui
entame lui aussi une traversée du désert
commence à peine à écrire ses propres
mémoires de guerre loin de la rumeur du
monde
dans le tumulte des hommes et des
événements la solitude était ma
tentation maintenant
elle est mon
amie de quel autre se contenter quand on
a rencontré
l'histoire avec ses souvenirs de la
France Libre qui ont la force du
témoignage de Gaulle quitte le statut
d'écrivain militaire qu' avait acquis
dans les années 30 pour celui d'écrivain
d'histoire
un écrivain ne comprend ce qui lui
arrive que lorsqu'il l'écrit deg a
l'ambition d'édifier une œuvre et de se
démarquer ainsi de Churchill qui selon
lui s'est contenté de je cite mettre
beaucoup de choses bout à
[Musique]
bout pourtant Winston Churchill est
celui des deux que l'Académie suédoise a
choisi de consacrer en
pr Nobel de
littérature que disule pas sa
déception Mme pas la peine de se
déplacer jusquà Stockholm Enie sa
[Musique]
femme
il ne fait guerre de doute à l'époque
que cette annéelà la récompense est
moins motivé par des préoccupations
littéraires que par un souci politique
et diplomatique en fait Sir Winston
espéit le prix Nobel de la paix qui ira
finalement à Albert schweizzer qu'il
moque en privé mais il se résigne à
accepter son Nobel lorsqu'il apprend que
le chèque est d'un montant de 12000
livres sterling non
imposable
[Musique]
quant à de Gaulle la parution de ses
Mémoires de guerre un an plus tard chez
plomb éditeur choisi parce qu'il avait
été celui des grands points carré F ou
Churchill a un grand rentissement tant
dans le monde politique que littéraire
dans de nombreux
[Musique]
pays
désormais inscrit au plus prestigieux
des palmarès littéraires Churchill a
tout de même été sacré écrivain entre
François moriac et Ernest Mingue excusé
du peu or l'Académie suédoise est censé
distinguer un écrivain et non un
polygraphe doué FRU d'histoire et
assisté par un atelier de
lorsqu'on les relie avec le recul du
temps Charles de Gaulle est bien des
deux
l'écrivain un classique dont l'esprit
est gouverné par un absolu de la langue
française et donc de
l'écriture toute sa vie il s'était fait
une certaine idée de la France à travers
la littérature qu'il avait formé à
jamais qu'importe au fond puisque ce qui
en reste c'est d'abord l'histoire d'une
amitié contrariée carpionnée entre deux
hommes que liait une admiration
réciproque deux monstres sacré au destin
façonné par la houle de
l'histoire je savais qu'il n'était pas
ami de l'Angleterre mais j'ai toujours
retrouvé en lui l'esprit et les
conceptions que le mot France évoquera
éternellement tout au long des pages de
[Musique]
l'histoire les incidents rudes et
pénibles qui se produisirent à maint
reprise entre nous en raison des
frictions de nos deux caractère ont
influé sur mon attitude à l'égard du
Premier ministre mais non point sur mon
jugement Winston Churchill m'app paru
d'un bout à l'autre du drame comme le
grand champion d'une grande entreprise
et le grand artiste d'une grande
histoire
[Musique]